[Music]
today's question comes from kirk in
virginia
kirk says my wife says we
can
that's not really a complete sentence my
wife says we enjoy we
feel we can enjoy things in life such as
taking our son to disney world because
she knows
my wife says we can't enjoy things in
life such as taking our son to disney
world because she knows i'll be grumpy
about it later or bring up how much
money it cost
we're on baby step 3 and have no debt
except for mortgage and about 60 grand
in savings how do i try and not be so
anxious about spending the money we have
i hate seeing the number disappear from
our accounts but don't want my life to
feel like we can't enjoy
milestones
dave can i tell you something i struggle
with this too
i wrestle with this
um
man i had a hard conversation with my
son recently about this same thing
uh
you've you've been working with couples
for 30 years man
how what have you seen when it comes to
this
well i mean it's living in scarcity it's
a it's a but it's a saver mentality not
a spender mentality yeah yeah he enjoys
saving money more and he enjoys spending
it yeah
and um the spender enjoys the experience
enjoys spending it more than they enjoy
saving it
and a balanced mature approach is is
that we have the ability to do both
and get joy from them but we just know
our default our natural
tendency is to move towards one or the
other i'm a spender yeah so by nature
it's not hard for me to move even today
to enjoy money but the only way i enjoy
money now
is knowing that i've got i've done my
work over here um
it's like i had to um
you know i i i had to get my homework
done before i could go out to play you
know kind of thing and uh but in the old
days i just went out to play and the
homework didn't get done that's called
immaturity and so you spend money you
don't and you don't know anything saved
so then the opposite of that is this
person who's a little bit more scarcity
savers generally are more scarcity
versus abundance spenders have a
tendency to be more abundance versus
scarcity it's not always true but it's
pretty much rachel's book know yourself
know your money she goes into a lot of
this stuff
but um the uh uh
i mean for me i think you just saying it
out loud right there is a big thing it's
huge that that kind of starts to set you
free
and you go okay
why is it i'm saving money there you go
is it only for security
no
your intellect will tell you that's not
the only reason now your emotions might
tell you that's the only reason but i'm
saving money so that yeah it comes down
to so that's for what yeah yeah and so
and and
we all know in our intellect
uh some of us are more emotional about
it than others but we all know in our
intellect that
that that four year old when you blink
they'll be 14.
so you better do disney while you can
yeah you don't get a second go-round on
that puppy
because you can
now you don't get to go use that same
line as an excuse to go into credit card
debt to go to disney
because you're broke and you're out of
control no you got you owe that kid
stability at home so you got to do your
work first you do your homework before
you got to play but now you got your
homework done yeah don't sit there and
read a book go out and play
you know and and so you've got to force
yourself to do that and part of it is if
you have if you look at the money and
you say the money that's left after we
do this is more than enough
it's we're fine yeah
and that's kind of the facts or your
friends you know almost your trauma
stuff where you guys deal with trauma
and you say well you know i'm afraid
the emotions are making the decision
and
facts are my friends i got plenty of
money i got money yeah so i can do both
and i'm okay yeah notify yourself that
you're okay james clear writes about um
changing habits and and
i love the way he framed it i've never
heard it framed this way which is if you
want to change your habits the best way
to do that long term is to change your
identity first
and this is an identity
call out that his wife makes here that
it's almost not worth doing things as a
family because of who you're gonna be
later
yeah and as a as a dad this ring's true
my wife calls it sunday afternoon dad
she's like it just kind of becomes
everybody just back up a little bit
because dad's starting to he's tired
from getting up at church and he's ready
for work tomorrow i don't want to be
that i don't i want to be like i would
rather my kids when they're 18 remember
man remember sunday afternoons were such
chaos and fun and we never knew what was
going to happen because dad was bonkers
versus you don't get around dad so this
to me starts with i don't want to be
known as the grumpy dad every time we
did something joyful with money with
money because that says you've that says
to my kids i value the money more than i
do time with them that's right
and if i'm pouting about it if i'm
pouting about it if i'm being ugly about
it if i am rolling my eyes that my wife
and kids want to have joy in their life
and so i think i want to say okay i'm
going to be the dad who loves spending
time with my family and let's reverse
engineer that what's the money going to
be that it's going to take for us to go
on these vacations and feel safe i love
that here's the thing you do for people
you love
your kids your spouse sometimes you do
stuff they want to do
a lot of times you do yes and you're not
a twerp about it yes find joy and them
having joy yeah i mean i there's stuff
there's a lot of stuff i mean i
i like people but i don't like social
settings at all
at all
but my wife
completely eats that stuff with a spoon
but this idea of standing around with a
drink in your hand and you go what do
you do shoot me oh god i just would
rather be
i'd rather be in the basement you know
reorganizing the dirt i mean something
god mighty but but you know so but but
i had to to make this a conscious
decision to not be in constant eye roll
mode and just go this is something gives
her life yeah
and so i'm gonna go and not steal her
joy
every time we go to a party and then in
return
i found out i don't have to go to all
the parties right right i get a i get i
get payback for it but i didn't even
know that was coming but yeah i had to
make that decision relationally yeah and
i still kind of as you can tell
frequently have to remake that decision
but but when you get a new corvette i
bet you say sure you'll go for a ride
and she goes sure dave i'd love to
[Laughter]
and she grits her teeth through the ride
you know i mean i think that's part i
think it's part of being a a great
husband a great spouse a great parent is
leaning in and part of the joy being no
i must hank and i went hunting this
weekend i would have had a better
outcome had i been not with a 10 year
old in the woods or 11 year old because
they're known for how quiet how quiet
they are
but i wouldn't have traded that weekend
for anything yeah right we'll talk about
this weekend it was pretty chaotic we'll
talk about that for the rest of our
lives and so it's making those types of
trades
and in this situation
kirk you got the money bro the good news
was like kirk is he's so self-aware oh
yeah he asked the question his wife
didn't write this he wrote it yes great
great man start with identity i want to
be a dad
who loves being with my kids and my wife
and i love having fun with him yeah now
what does that look what i have to do to
make that identity happen and i'm going
to allocate
a portion of the money that
i know is going to make me a little bit
uncomfortable and i'm going to overcome
that discomfort to still have joy